COMING UP NEXT.
GOOD NIGHT.
♪♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"
TONIGHT."
FORK CLIFF DRIVER MADE THE
MISTAKE MAKING FUN OF ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE ONLINE.
THE PRESS AND FACEBOOK TEAMED TO
UP DESTROY HIM.
THE TERRIFYING ALLIANCE BETWEEN
ELITE MEDIA AND WOKE CAPITAL.
FIRST TONIGHT OFFICIALLY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS LED BY
PEOPLE OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER
THE KOREAN WAR.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI.
IN REALITY, POWER HAS SHIFTED.
THE REAL LEADERS OF THE PARTY
TODAY ARE YOUNG PIE YEARS
RADICALS LIKE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
TODAY BIDEN REVEALED HIS OWN
CLIMATE PLAN.
LIKE THE GREEN NEW DEAL, IT
WOULD PUT THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
ECONOMY IN THE HANDS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT WOULD COST ABOUT
$6.7 TRILLION.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
IT'S EQUAL TO TWO FULL YEARS OF
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL BUDGET.
BIDEN SAID WE MUST GIVE DEMOCRAT
THIS POWER IMMEDIATELY OR ELSE
THE ENTIRE PLANET WILL BECOME
UNINHABITABLE.
>> SIGNS TELL US HOW WE ACT IN
THE NEXT 12 YEARS WILL DETERMINE
THE LIVABILITY OF OUR PLANET.
TODAY, I'M ANNOUNCING MY PLAN
FOR CLEAN ENERGY REVOLUTION.
OUTLINES WHAT WE HAVE TO DO MEET
THIS CHALLENGE HEAD ON AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST MONTHLY
$7 TRILLION IN SECURING OUR
FUTURE SO THAT BY 2050 UNITED
STATES WILL BE 100% CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY WILL NET ZERO MISSIONS.
>> Tucker: JUST 12 YEARS TO ACT
WHEN THE PLANET BECOMES
UNINHABITABLE.
IT SOUNDS FAMILIAR.
BIDEN TOOK THAT LINE DIRECTLY
FROM THE YOUNG PIONEER HERSELF.
>> THE WORLD WILL END IN 12
YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS OUR WORLD WAR II.
>> Tucker: LIKE, THIS IS OUR
WORLD WAR II.
ACTUALLY BIDEN BARRED MORE THAN
JUST LINE.
AT LEAST FIVE UNANIMOUSES IN --
INSTANCES JOE BIDEN QUOTED
VERBATIM OR NONE THEM ARE CITED.
THAT'S ANOTHER BENEFIT OF
CLIMATE.